lucifer 5b is one hell of a season for
lucy fans packed with laughter tears and
destinies fulfilled
yipikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video i'm answering the big questions
about how and why that happened to
lucifer plus what to expect from dan
chloe mays and the rest of team lucifer
in season six
obviously spoilers ahead so take care
god's arrival on earth is a crucial part
of lucifer finally having to confront
his issues with his father and the rest
of his celestial family
despite the family dinner going badly
lucy and dad are able to repair their
relationship with god telling his
devilish son that he does love him just
before he reveals he's retiring and
going to live with the goddess in her
universe
this sets up the climactic showdown
between lucifer and michael the
two final contenders to take over the
position of almighty
the two brothers face off at the la
memorial coliseum
a fitting location given everything
associated with the word coliseum the
most famous of which in rome was home to
gladiatorial battles and public
executions michael has a majority of the
other angels on his side
however because he doesn't have the
unanimous support needed his attempt to
claim the title of god fails
so he tries to kick off a celestial
battle between the two sides
something neatly foreshadowed earlier in
the ninth episode
you have to play in the family war zone
do i chloe takes down a couple of angels
with melted down demon blade bullets
and to avoid further bloodshed the twin
brothers agree to fight each other
michael has the advantage of the flaming
sword the divine weapon that lucifer
used to send his mother into another
dimension
and which has the power to erase from
existence even immortal beings like
lucifer
and when michael slices a curtain to
lucy's midriff it's a callback to what
dan did when he brandished azrael's
blade against lucifer in the season two
episode trip to stabbytown
i know you ate my pudding as lucifer and
michael struggle over control of the
sword
chloe disables it by pulling out the key
and as lucifer goes to pick up the blade
asriel appears i'm sorry lou
asriel was ella's special ghost friend
in the season 3 bonus episode boo
normal and as the angel of death she
shows up when somebody is about to die
just at that moment michael brutally
stabs chloe with zadkiel's staff which
is ironically but also importantly the
last remaining piece of the tree of life
chloe dies in lucifer's arms accepting
she was never to blame for dan's death
so free of guilt she reunites with her
father in heaven
and the sandwiches you see them enjoying
together are an easter egg to the second
season episode my little monkey when
chloe made the same ones for trixie egg
sandwiches
the decker family tradition so good
grandpa used to bring me this sandwich
every thursday after acting class so
lucifer refuses to accept chloe's death
and decides to go to heaven to bring her
back
despite michael saying his twin will die
doing that you know because of the whole
you're banished from heaven and would be
instantly incinerated if you returned
thing
nonetheless lucifer flies up to heaven
and survives the journey thanks to the
immortality contained in lilith's ring
when lilith blew her immortality into
the ring it transformed from white to
black
so notice how the ring now has little
white swirls in it showing how the
protection's been activated and its
power is being used up
with some help from mr said outbitch
lucifer finds chloe and tells her she
must go back
proving his selfless love for her he
takes off the ring which is protecting
him
and tells her i choose you
chloe i love you
this is a bittersweet moment once more
for deca star fans who've been waiting
for those three little words to quote
ella i was so ready to have my decker
star dreams crushed again but
the couple are separated again with
chloe returning to earth while lucifer
seemingly burns up
as chloe comes back to life michael
tries to kill her again but the
resurrected chloe discovers she now has
immense strength
enough to go up against even an angel
like michael thanks to the necklace part
of the flaming sword that she's still
holding
and as she picks up asriel's blade she
seems like she's on the verge of
actually killing michael
remember from season two that the blade
entices those who wield it to murder
however lucifer suddenly reappears
pulling the detective
out of the blade's enchantment so how
did lucy survive
lucifer himself doesn't seem to know
however there are several clues in
season 5
and earlier seasons which can give us an
answer first of all we hadn't heard
about lucifer dying if he tried to
return to heaven
until michael said it in season 5. we
know michael lies and plays mind games
which we've seen him do to both the men
a deal and god and for all we know at
some point he managed to convince his
twin of this fact meaning that if lucy
believed it especially if it was tied to
his own feelings of guilt over his
rebellion then because
angels have the power to self-actualize
he might have made himself burn up
and perhaps it's that crucial moment of
self-sacrifice together with him
accepting that he really does love her
that rids him of all his feelings of
shame about whether he deserved to be
accepted back into heaven
that could in turn stop him from making
real the belief that he deserved to burn
as a punishment for returning to his
family home
so in effect he saved himself also
notice the importance of the word choose
in what lucifer says to chloe as he
gives her the ring
no you don't have to do that i know i
don't have to i choose to
what i choose you
that echoes what chloe said just before
dying we make our own choices
i chose to meet you now we know just how
crucial the theme of choice has been
throughout the entire series after all
lucifer has so often spoken about his
belief that he has very little or no
choice in life because of god using him
and others as what lucy's called
pawns in his game if you mean his plan
to continually manipulate and control me
then agreed it's my dad's fault i mean
i'm sure it was him manipulating things
like he always does
so it's absolutely huge that lucifer
recognizes in this moment that he does
have the power to make his own decisions
and i think that his choice to give up
his own life so that chloe could have a
second chance on earth helped make him
feel
worthy again and in control of his own
existence
and i imagine that this was what god
hoped for his fallen son
all along it's not up to me anymore
you'll figure it out
this idea of lucifer making his own
choices in life and not making excuses
for everything by blaming his father was
an
important point that came up in a
previous discussion between lucy and
linda about why he didn't want to tell
chloe he was the devil
because she doesn't have a choice to see
neither do i it's all part of his
master plan the toy with his that's an
excuse
you're doing the same thing as him now
by not telling chloe the truth you're
taking
her choice away tied him with this
notion of choosing
is lucy being able to finally tell chloe
that he loves her
something he almost did in the
mid-season finale deca star hopes were
temporarily scuppered though after the
disastrous family dinner where god's
somewhat cryptic answers to lucifer's
questions about whether he ever loved
him made lucy believe he wasn't truly
able to love chloe
i am my father's son like him i am
incapable of love
again because angels self-actualize if
lucifer believed he couldn't love then
that would prevent him from taking the
final step in acknowledging his true
feelings for the detective
fortunately by the time god decides to
leave with goddess he admits to lucy
that he could have been a better father
and then
adds i can say something i've wanted to
for a long time
i love you son this was an enormous
emotional moment for lucy as these were
things he never
expected to hear from his father
remember lucy said as much after he
heard god johnson say similarly
emotional things in season two
you said some things that i think i wish
he'd always said to me
i'm bloody furious i realized that my
father would never say those things to
me but now
finally having this moment with his real
father is the reason why lucifer's later
finally able to say those words to chloe
with lucifer's miraculous return from
heaven all the angels including michael
bend the knee to him
signaling he has their unanimous support
as god and when lucifer raises a flaming
sword above his head
you can see the golden sun mural right
above him together with the olympic
flames on either side
a nice reference to lucifer's name the
light bringer
oh my me we can also see how the seeds
for this epic moment were planted all
the way back in one of lucifer's therapy
sessions with linda in season one before
you fell you were known as
semi-el the lightbringer i don't go by
that name anymore that was a name that
connotated your father's love for you we
know that god finally told lucy that he
loved him this season but in that season
one episode
linda also suggested that when god cast
lucifer out of heaven and into hell it
was a gift
it was an act of love because you are
his favorite sons but here's the thing
when angels fall they also
rise all you have to do is embrace all
that you
are she may have thought they were
talking in metaphors at that time but as
it turned out the doctor was extremely
prescient
by the end of season five lucifer did
indeed rise to heaven after accepting
that he was loved by his father and
embracing his true feelings for chloe
who notably was also a gift from god
and talking of chloe i noticed that
lucifer made several mentions in the
finale that it wasn't chloe's time to go
yet
and that she was still needed back on
earth which i think is setting up a
season six plot point the worlds don't
teach you chloe
chloe's second chance at life is also a
reminder that second chances are
essentially the overarching theme of the
series with lucifer even showing mercy
to michael who was willing to kill both
him and the detective
in my time here on earth i've learned
everyone deserves a second chance
even you michael by the end of season
five mays too found she was given a
second chance at happiness when eve
returned to her and our favorite demon
discovered she'd grown a soul through
the time she's spent building
relationships with people on earth
as for linda she reconciles with her
grown-up daughter who she gave up as a
teenage mother
and through her relationship with amena
deal linda has taken a second chance to
form a family with him and charlie
and when god comes to appreciate how he
failed his wife by neglecting her
through his work he takes the
opportunity of a second chance to build
a new life with her by going to live in
her universe
over the course of the series dan has
also reformed himself and grown to be a
better
person he was of course cruelly killed
in the fifth season and when a menadil
visited heaven he discovered dan wasn't
there
as his lingering feelings of guilt about
his past mistakes in life had taken him
to hell
however i think that with some help from
team lucifer in season six
dan will find a way to leave hell and
ascend to heaven just like mr said out
[ __ ] managed to do but i know i took
your advice
i faced my family my guilt
through the door yep finally and boom
heaven mr said out bitch's ark is a mini
version of lucifer's
they were both stuck in hell in the
first episode of season five with lucy
agreeing to help lee
find the source of his guilt which
stemmed from the time he felt too
ashamed to visit his family for his
sister's baby shower
although lucifer berates lee for his
failings it's clear that the scene is
meant to illuminate lucy's innermost
feelings about his own celestial family
if you go through that door it's only a
matter of time before you
screw up again so you'd rather stay away
for all eternity
this isn't just about me is it whose
hell is this anyway
like lee lucifer decided to go through
the door to his family home when he
faced up to his shame and risked
everything by returning to heaven which
in turn broke him out of his own
metaphorical hell loop
likewise dan will have to find the key
to walking through the door that's
keeping him
in his own personal hell it'll be
interesting to see what in particular
dan feels so guilty over still in season
6
and who will be able to visit him to
help him escape his own hell loop
unlike many other lucy fans i'll be
doing another re-watch of the show to
look for more clues before season 6. but
as much as we love our streaming
services it can be really frustrating
when the tv show you want to watch isn't
available in your country
thanks to nordvpn the sponsor of this
video though you can make these geo
restrictions a thing of the past
although some shows like brooklyn 99 and
friends are on a break from netflix in
the us
with nord you can still watch these on
netflix in other countries such as the
uk
use the nordvpn app to pick a server in
another location
and browse the internet as if you were
there nord won't slow you down either
and you're still able to get super fast
speeds when connected
there's no bandwidth throttling and
thanks to nord's secure encrypted
connection you get to keep your online
activity private from your internet
service provider
on top of that nord has a no log policy
so it doesn't record or retain details
of your online activity when you're
connected to its service
for a limited time nordvpn are offering
all our viewers a huge discount plus one
month free
just visit nordvpn.comflix or go to the
link in the video description to grab
the offer
or use coupon code flicks when you check
out
there'll be more lucifer 5b episodes
coming up including easter eggs and
things you missed
plus season 6 theories tap here to watch
the full playlist which will have each
new video as soon as i upload it there's
also a link in the video description
so what did you think of the season five
finale and do you have any theories on
what you'd like to see in season six
leave your comments below and if you
enjoyed this then a like and a share are
hugely appreciated
tap left for my next loose of a video or
tap write for something else you're sure
to like
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippee kai movie lovers